[Music]
tomorrow night is Game one of the World
Series featuring our hometown team the
Los Angeles Dodgers and get this it's
gonna be over a hundred degrees tomorrow
in LA by far the hottest World Series
game ever I got a solution oh wow that's
one of our cameraman fake temporary
solution well you were just saying it's
gonna be hot so you know I could build a
dome over Dodger Stadium
you know dome it up that's right don't
you want to build a dome over Dodger
Stadium yeah I mean some of the guys
have a construction business on the side
so we'll do it yeah Tony the game is
tomorrow night building a dome would be
a multi-year project uh we could build
you a dome in like 40 minutes Tony it
took you guys three weeks to build
Andy's podium over there yeah but that
was after a very big lunch
look Conan just venmo me a billion
dollars my handle is at pony domes 1
billion ok it's not gonna happen also
why would I be the one to pay for the
dome all right I thought you owned the
Dodgers you thought I owned the Los
Angeles Dodgers yeah we all did why do
you guys think I own the Dodgers because
you're so cool yeah you got big hair you
drive a cool car you're always eating
the best sandwiches I assumed you owned
the professional sports team dumbest
thing I've ever heard
yeah well I'm not too bright
so what do you want me to get started on
that dome how about you finish this
sketch first what's going on here Tony
the cameraman everybody that's if that
if we do that when it's proof we can do
these about anything on it you want to
buy an onion you sell onions
oh sure we're also London's right guys
why would you sell onions if you're not
a farmer
well we've got is half halfway there I
mean we I was just workshopping it okay
back to the drawing board I know
everyone's you know I get it huh Oh God
so that's in thank you oh my god we
should just start saying tony has a
tumor in his head hey Gordon yeah time
for Tony's death watch karna you smell
that burning rubber
I don't smell burning rubber well I do I
got a tumor okay well Tony you should
hey I got a fire hose what for the
burning rubber
there is no burning rubber Tony I know I
got a tumor it causes what's called an
olfactory illusion Tony what's your
point I don't know
it really hurts there are the criminals
right there sitting in the doc
then we don't need to think of any
reason for Tony to have a scheme uh-huh
I know we're great to have something on
it let's go as you know BuzzFeed
publishes hundreds of lists on their
site every day I just told me down and
spit on
[Music]
you